the direct
path number four
i'm gonna balance things out with this
direct
path
the first three direct paths have been
a lot about non-duality
they've been a lot about
self-realization
for an extremely important reason
which is that self-realization
is what enables the
highest morality in the
self-actualization
otherwise the self-actualization is
blind
and that is exactly the problem
one of our main most upstream maladies
that civilization
faces is
self-actualization that is completely
blind
to the one infinite creator
and that's why i'm going to balance out
this direct path teaching where it's
not only going to be focused on
non-duality
and the self-realization side of things
which we can call the
inner side of things but we're going to
balance that out
by also explaining how it affects the
outer which is the self-actualization
side of things
again the reason why self-realization is
critical
is because it's what enables all of the
highest
morality in the self-actualization
process
when you actually truly know
that this is the one infinite creator
expressing itself
through all of us then you
realize that the other is actually the
self
and then you don't cause harm and
suffering onto other people but rather
you
influence them extremely positively and
impact their well-being
and flourishing and prosperity in
service to others true
others true actual genuine
compassionate authentic service to
others
so we're gonna set the intention for
this direct path number four as know
thyself
these two words know thyself we've
talked about
prolifically on the program they
are the most important
delphic maxim which is of the greeks
approximately 2500 years ago written on
top
of the temple of apollo at delphi know
thyself
why is this the most important delphic
maxim
and what does know thyself mean much of
modernity thinks that that just means
self-actualization oh
i'm gonna know myself meaning i'm gonna
know my purpose and i'm gonna go do that
in the world
okay cool but your purpose can be
extremely
greedy and it can be extremely
egotistical it can be very
megalomaniac it can be very psychopathic
and that's what so many people are
falling into right now is that process
and then they undergo a process of
needing to subscribe to all of the
self-help teachings
and you can sort of see people ranking
up from egoic levels of consciousness
slowly to some of the
the tony robbins and jordan peterson
which is like the self-help
which sort of ranks them up a little bit
above egoic to
maybe social and ethno levels of
consciousness
but then really you only start
getting into some of the more higher
levels of awakening
to know thyself and what that truly
means when you begin experiencing world
level consciousness
and transpersonal levels of
consciousness
and this is when you begin sort of
exploring the planetary mystic
traditions and mysticism is all about
union
or yoga or hypnosis with what with god
with source with infinity
and so once you sort of begin anchoring
infinity in you you become
infinity where you become god you have
that entheogenic
process when that happens that's when
you usually attain some sort of non-dual
awareness and that's the
ultimate self-realization that occurs
and when that occurs then everything you
do in your self-actualization
creative artistic expression process
is going to be of the absolute highest
morality
the absolute highest ethics and that's
exactly what we need
in our civilization our society our
social fabric
needs very high level of consciousness
in terms of having actually felt the
kingdom of god within they've anchored
non-duality anchored
infinity they know that they are the one
infinite creator and that the
quote other is actually the self and
they need to be in service to that
imagine if the fortune 500 ceos of the
planet
in the u.n general assembly the usa
congress the 2
200 billionaires around the planet or
the 225
000 ultra high net worth people around
the planet
if they had felt states of non-dual
awareness
if they had underwent this process of
know thyself
this multi-thousand-year
wisdom that is currently being
just swept to the side no problem and
you wonder why
modernity is struggling ethically
morally and spiritually why it feels
like it's so de-sacralized
no [ __ ] [ __ ]
we know exactly why
you have to undergo a process of union
with infinity with god with source you
have to
unleash that kingdom of god within you
for you to know that you
are that in order for you to have a high
level of morality and ethics
so that the quote economic machinery is
actually
[ __ ] aligned with ecology so it's
actually aligned with this original
living wisdom of the planet earth
no [ __ ] that's how to have sustainable
growth a growing pie for everybody
when you know that our being is truly
shared that is what love is
and now you wonder oh why was alan
making
atlas why was atlas making the first
three direct path videos all about
non-duality and self-realization
well because that's why
we need it now more than ever to wake
the [ __ ]
up to who we truly are and why we are
here
expressing ourselves as that one
infinite creator so we can have the
highest level of morality and ethics in
everything we do as a self-actualization
that's why i'm doing it
don't you want to know who you are not
on a self-actualization level
but on a self-realization level the
nature of reality
is the simultaneity of the inner and the
outer
but we're so deeply in the outer in the
west
in the self-actualization meanwhile
india
and a lot of the east had been in a
state of deep
inner self-realization and not so much
on the self-actualization
and so now you see the synthesis of the
two that's the synthesis in many ways of
spirituality and science
or the synthesis of east and west or the
synthesis of indigeneity and modernity
the synthesis of usa and china the
synthesis of the left and the right
politically in the usa
once you begin seeing it this way
that's ultimately what we want to do we
want to go
in and self-realize as well as go out
and self-actualize and express ourselves
as infinity
but in order for you to express yourself
as infinity you have to recognize that
you
are that first and foremost that way
everything you do is going to be of the
highest morality
okay so that's our intention is to know
thyself
and that means two things
self-realization inner
self-actualization outer
that's what know thyself means first of
all
and then the other intention is to know
yourself as the one
infinite creator that is doing this
we've been eternally doing this
before this we're going to keep doing it
after this
even that idea of before and after is a
complete illusion
and to know that that is what this is
that that is what you are that that is
what i am that we are god we are source
we are the one infinite creator
that is expressing itself like this to
have that anchored as a self-realization
and to be anchored in that as you
self-actualize
is ultimately what this direct path
teaching
is going to influence you so positively
on your life
okay so let's walk through these steps
in this process
so the first thing that i need
us to do in order for this to be
efficacious
is you have to empty your cup
meaning you have all of these world
views you have
all of these lenses that you carry right
now you have all these [ __ ]
onion layers that you carry with you
that you think
are serving you right now but they're
not
if you haven't self-realized these are
not serving you they're actually what's
causing you immense amounts of suffering
and pain why do you feel
bliss for only one minute out of every
24 hours
do you think that that's [ __ ] how you
should be living life that you should
only feel
peace for one minute out of every 24
hours
no that's what self-realization gives
you
it gives you an eternal bliss and peace
you literally 24 hours a day after you
commune with that one infinite creator
you realize it
every single day every 24 hours
you are feeling bliss and peace not for
one [ __ ] minute not for 10 minutes
and not even for one
hour if you're only feeling it for one
hour
you're not there you should be feeling
it every single moment because that's
the truth
of our existence that's the truth of our
being sought [ __ ] on nonda existence
consciousness bliss
so first of all empty your [ __ ] cup
empty all your world views out empty
all of your lenses that you see the
world
empty all of it out this is a very
perennial teaching
what they have those that are inquiring
do is to empty themselves peel all those
layers off okay
now that all those layers are off all
your lenses and world views are off you
have a complete
openness right that's critical here a
complete openness
i need you to get into an environment
that's highly conducive for this process
with this level of openness
be in a place that doesn't have much
noise pollution if any at all
be in a place that you can be alone you
can be sitting
comfortably and you can take some
inhalations
anchor yourself with your breath
and how beautiful it is to just be alive
and to just be
tapping into your body tapping into your
heart
and as you do that process now i want
you to feel into your heart feeling to
you being the most compassionate you've
ever been in your life right now
i want you to give only compassion to
absolutely
everything i want you to see the entire
planet earth
as a divine
keep breathing keep tapping into your
heart
focus on the earth being absolutely
divine focus on every single one
of the eight billion people as gods and
goddesses
that they are all unique expressions of
infinity
give compassion keep breathing
give love
keep pouring that compassion and that
love out of your heart have it radiate
out of your heart and all across the
planet
all across all of the different people
all of the different species our entire
planet
earth as our home have it radiate out
your love and compassion from your heart
now if you've done these first two steps
right you'll be able to
feel an openness from your heart
you'll be able to feel that you've sort
of shed these layers
emptied your cup and you've given this
radiant compassion
from your heart and that you've seen the
whole creation
as divine and that every person as
divine
now that's a prerequisite to even
going into this third step of having
this deliberate focus
what you're doing here is you're
training
your awareness to focus
that's what is taught in so many of the
perennial
mystic lineages is that you use the
breath
as a tool whether it's through anapana
or any of these other breathing
techniques and exercises where you
eradicate the deepest roots of the
monkey mind
where the monkey mind is just sending
you everywhere where you can't even
focus and do that compassion exercise
because then
before you know it you're thinking about
music or you're thinking about sex
or you're thinking about alcohol or
you're thinking about your job or you're
thinking about
that rude thing that that person told
you that's the monkey mind
it's driving you insane
it's driving a ridiculous amount of ego
in your life it's driving you to be
extremely reactive
and the only thing that extinguishes the
nasty roots of the monkey mind
is for you to surgically eradicate the
roots
of the monkey mind and take a divine
free will
manifester control of your destiny
in order for you to do that you have to
get used to the breath
it creates that pause
and that pause
it enables you to redirect from negative
suffering emotions towards more positive
emotions that
serve you so you have to have this
deliberate focus
practice with the breath now
as you get good at that you can start
doing things like manifesting now
what i mean by manifesting is even that
that simple breath repetition you're
doing you're manifesting yourself away
from negativity towards positivity but
then you also do things like
manifestations really important not only
for your intention with know thyself for
self-realization
but also as you know we made a video
about this on creator consciousness
where manifestation is so much about
self-actualization as well
future authoring your north star and
taking the incremental steps to execute
that
and so the breath helps you
know yourself on both the
self-realization level and the
self-actualization level it
enables you to become more of a
manifesto towards
positive abundant bliss peace states of
expression
as well as achieving some sort of divine
transcendent north star
that is in service to others
and now what we'll do is we'll explore
number five which is the juxtaposition
so what's going to happen is as you get
really good at this deliberate focus
at creating the pause with your breath
as you manifest more and more positive
states of expression
what you'll also notice is that it gives
you more and more like you're doing
repetitions like you're getting really
good at shooting three pointers or
playing the violin
is that you're becoming better and
better
at creating this pause that then enables
you to do things like
see this juxtaposition we're not only
showing you the juxtaposition of a
negative state
and then you have an elevated view it
gives you like a bird's eye view of the
topology
where you can literally see the
bifurcation in the decision tree where
on one side it's negativity and
suffering and on the other
side it's positivity and well-being and
so it gives you this
macro level bird's eye topological view
of your decision tree
but then also that same thing is true
for this
other juxtaposition that we're about to
give you which is the juxtaposition
of recognizing the difference between
awareness or consciousness when it's
colored in this case by thoughts
emotions
feelings beliefs or objects
so there's all of this different
coloration and experience that it's
undergoing
versus awareness or consciousness
without any of that
awareness or consciousness when it's
just pure and bare
and empty without that and that is
possible
to know what that is and when you get
really good at creating that
juxtaposition
when you say okay well what is my
consciousness or awareness
like when it's not colored
by objects and emotions and feelings and
beliefs
what is it like when i'm not excessively
ruminating and thinking but when i'm
just pure bear empty awareness or
consciousness
the analogies that we've been using on
the program are like this device
the screen itself without anything
that's on it no
images no movies no social media none of
the stuff
no texting no phone calls that's pure
bear awareness
as soon as you have an application
that's running that's a thought or an
emotion
and very similarly to
the paper in the words the words are the
thoughts the emotions the feelings the
beliefs and the objects
but the paper itself
is the pure bear empty awareness
okay so on top of your pure
bare empty awareness or consciousness
you are constantly on a moment-to-moment
basis
experiencing the writing
or experiencing on the screen the images
and the movies
but you have to create a juxtaposition
for you to actually
know that that's what's happening
because that is what god is
that is what source is that is what
infinity
is it is this eternal infinite bliss
peace
awareness that is pure bare and empty
that is undergoing an infinite amount of
expression
on it that's the idea the paper
itself the screen itself is empty it's
eternal
it's infinite and it's undergoing an
infinite amount of expression
and the expression that it's receiving
on that paper on that screen
is all of the words it's all of the
objects the feelings the emotions the
beliefs and the thoughts
but you have to
you have to take that juxtaposition see
that pause
see that difference between pure bear
empty awareness that's not colored
versus when it is colored and recognize
that that is god
and that is what i mean by b infinity
number six
anchor infinity anchor non-dual
awareness
anchor god unleash the kingdom of god
within you
recognize that you are source i am
source we come from the same source
our awareness is shared
you can think about it this way these
are pupils
right look at the blackness of every
pupil
of all 8 billion in this one creation
that
blackness of every single pupil is
shared
so that awareness or that consciousness
out of the blackness of every pupil is
shared
now the iris that is around that pupil
is a different coloration and that is
what the unique expression
of the infinity is undergoing but you
have to
think about it that way you have to
think about it like at the pupil level
look at someone else's [ __ ] pupil
and realize that the awareness or the
consciousness on a
super macro god source infinity level is
[ __ ] shared and another way to view
that
is like a massive brain that has a bunch
of different nerve endings
this is god's brain this is source's
brain this is
infinity's brain and we are a bunch of
different nerve endings and this
creation is just one
expression of that
so that's self-realization when you've
had that profound
satori moment of enlightenment and you
recognize that
once you have that then
everything else you do going outward
is going to be of the highest morality
you
have to go all the way inward you have
to drill
all the way to water which we talked
about in the direct path number three
go all the way to water
don't stop at that first cup
and then go oh i have it so many people
stop at that like 90
mark and they intellectualize it
but hit the ocean and when you hit the
ocean
there's a satori moment you know it
there's a very
profound satori moment your entire
ego dissipates and dissolves instantly
because you recognize that you've been
holding on to the onion layers the whole
time
that those onion layers don't exist
that the only thing that exists is that
non-dual
infinite god source that is expressing
itself
and that that is what you are that is
what each of us are
now do you have something unique
artistically to express yes
are you doing that from an egotistical
place because you've never experienced
self-realization
likely yes that is why this content
is undergoing so much attention right
now that's why
people like rupert spyra and bentino
massaro
that's why people that are teaching the
non-dual tradition people that are
teaching the direct
path that are spiritual synthesis that
are trying to get people to awaken
to the true nature of our being in
existence
are getting so much attention right now
and there are even people
that aren't teaching that tradition that
are getting attention because they're
the ones that are teaching self-help
which is the one step above egoic level
consciousness which is who we were
mentioning earlier like people like tony
robbins and jordan peterson
they're getting even more attention
around the planet they're getting
millions of eyeballs around the planet
not just
tens of thousands and
what's happening is the planet's
awakening to realize that my
self-actualizing
because it's coming from a place of ego
is actually extremely cancerous
to not only the whole planet but to
myself
i'm suffering i only have one minute of
bliss every day okay i go to a tony
robbins event
or i like unleash the power within which
i've been to and i love or
you know we've had jordan peterson on
the show and you know stand up straight
with your shoulders back
you know this is great advice you know
cleaning up
your room in your space are is great
advice but that only gets you so far
what does that give you a second minute
of bliss every day
a third minute of bliss every day would
you have five minutes of bliss and peace
every day
now realize that above the teachings of
the self-help
to rank up your consciousness from egoic
to non-dual
to unsubscribe from all of the matrix
subscriptions and to get directly
to that direct path to self-realization
jump directly into these teachings jump
directly
into the planetary mystic traditions go
and sit
with a teacher of zolchen go and sit
at a theravada buddhism retreat go and
undergo a heroic dose of psilocybin
go and experience five amio dmt go and
read the dow to ching
go and study the sufi metaphysics
go and sit in a sweat lodge
go and dance and become god with the
african
vodon tradition go and
study the four books in the five
classics go and
immerse yourself in the advaita vedanta
style of direct path teachings
how many examples do you
have to hear before one of them goes oh
[ __ ]
yeah okay i'll finally go do that
because i'm done suffering
what i can have 24 hours of bliss and
peace
every day yes you can you deserve that
that's what you
inherently naturally are but have
forgotten
so get yourself there faster awaken
yourself faster
know yourself faster that's what's meant
by the delphic
maxim of know yourself is self-realize
and self-actualize
but in order to actually self-actualize
from a place of the highest morality you
have to know yourself in a self-realized
one infinite creator
state you have to know yourself as god
and source
in order for you to actually express
yourself from the absolute highest
morality and ethics
so what you're gonna get is you're gonna
get number seven which is the backlash
which is very common thing that happens
which is basically it's like the bucket
of crabs which
is like your family your friends people
online
will re will recognize that you begin
sort of saying some of these
non-dual perennial spiritual mystic
traditional commentaries where you begin
literally talking about advaita vinda
vedanta or you talk about
zokchen as something that has profoundly
impacted you where you have
attained a state of non-dual awareness
and you have
felt the kingdom of god within you and
that you've created that juxtaposition
and you understand what awareness means
pre-coloration which is exactly what
roomie meant when he said
you go from room to room looking for
that diamond necklace that is already
around your neck
and so when people don't get what roomie
means by that what they're going to do
is they're going to say
that oh yeah you think you know you
think you know
and they're going to pull you down with
their egoic consciousness because they
don't want to dedicate themselves to
truth
they do but their ego doesn't want them
to
their inherent attractor
inside of them is to seek to
recognize themselves as the one infinite
creator to pierce the veil and to awaken
to know themselves
but what's happening is that their egoic
level of consciousness because they
haven't
done a good job at taking care of the
hitchhiker of the ego
what's going on is that the hitchhiker
of the ego the monkey mind is driving
them around
in that car making all these negative
comments at you and on the internet at
people
that are undergoing this process where
they're dedicating themselves
with full blast
at truth because what happens is when
you dedicate yourself
towards truth at full blast like a
full-time job as a seeker
what happens is that the truth yields
and you gain that non-dual awareness you
gain that kingdom of god within you you
understand the dime necklace already
around your neck
and then you express yourself from that
and then there's no problems
in the social fabric no moral or ethical
problems
so do your best to sort of distance
yourself wisely gracefully peacefully
from egoic
consciousness that's trying to pull you
down in that bucket of crabs and that
big backlash
and also number eight don't box yourself
this is really critical
retain yourself as a unique expression
of infinity
because here's what happens usually is
that
we end up picking up something
like imagine if all that i did
from now on was solely talk about
just non-duality only
i would be boxing myself in just
nonduality imagine if i
also never talked about
self-actualization moving forward
imagine if i never talked imagine if we
never continued having guests on the
show that teach us about
neuroscience or that teach us about
biotechnology
or about blockchains and
cryptocurrencies and decentralization
imagine if we never had people come onto
the show that talk about
geopolitics and geoeconomics
or having high amounts of emotional
intelligence or having high amounts of
of a high digital quotient people that
come on the program that are really good
at using
tick-tock and different mediums of
technologies like virtual and augmented
realities
we're permanently going to continue
talking about all of those cutting edge
fields
as we talk about non-duality because
we're not ridiculous we're not gonna box
ourselves in
and that's similar with you as you
undergo this process
do not box yourself in don't box
yourself into shadow work and get stuck
doing healing and trauma work don't get
stuck there
don't get stuck in the
self-actualization processes of needing
to grow your business
eric weinstein has literally labeled
this the ego
the embedded growth obligation and it's
a perfect way to explain it
because why do you want to grow your
business
ask yourself that do you think it's
going to make you more
happy to increase your business
do you think that you're going to have
more peace by increasing your business
do you think you're going to have more
joy
do you actually have something that is
bringing the eradication of suffering to
the social fabric
because if you're eradicating poverty
and that's what you're doing in your
self-actualization
then you're actually potentially scaling
that is actually important and that's
even something that people like
myself and many others would help get
behind
but if you're literally trying to
peddle some sort of conspicuous
consumption
that then triggers a very vanity
state of consciousness in other people
think about it why do you want to have
an embedded growth obligation what
you're doing to promulgate that
are you actually going to be more
peaceful more happy
or is actually walking along the ocean
more often gonna bring that for you
or spending more time with your kids
gonna bring that for you
or is unpacking the planetary mystic
traditions going to do that for you
because that's the way to move yourself
from five minutes of bliss per day
to 24 [ __ ] hours of peace and bliss
alright thanks for tuning in to this
episode the direct path number four
i hope you can tell i've balanced this
out now because
the direct path one two and three the
links are in the bio below
were very deeply driven towards that
self-realization that non-duality
because i had just recently had my
satori moment like 10 days ago
and the reason
why i was so
deeply communicating that in the first
three
is because of that statement right here
it is the golden statement
of this episode you have to recognize
that your
self-realization of being the one
infinite creator
ensures that everything you do in your
self-actualization
expression of that is of the highest
morality
that's why and so i balance this one out
with some more of the self-actualization
so you can tell that know thyself
is both knowing yourself in a
self-realization way
and knowing yourself in a
self-actualization way it's the inner
and the outer which
is the nature of our reality is that
it's this and it's that it's both
so again
follow these steps listen to the video
again
listen to the first three direct path
videos undergo a process where
you do the repetitions to create that
juxtaposition
use the breath make the pause and then
see that pure
bear awareness
these are going to be your absolute best
resources
is the sheet of paper without the words
and the screen without the images in the
movie
rupert spire does a great job at
bringing those metaphors in
that help so much
and check him out check out rupert spire
and bentino massaro
their links are in the bio below as well
they've been two of the most profound
influences
on me so i love you very much let me
know what you think in the
comments below like the video subscribe
if you haven't already share the video
with other people
that need to see this and need to hear
this
and congratulations on any of the
progress that you've made on this direct
path
i'll keep balancing out these videos
with that know thyself from both a
self-realization and a
self-actualization perspective
but remember that key that
self-realization the inner work
is what ensures the highest level of
morality in your self-actualization in
the outer expression
that's the key takeaway from this
episode i love you very much
thanks for tuning in you will find the
diamond necklace that is already around
your neck
much love
namaste fam
peace